President Joe Biden went for dinner in
Washington DC later on Saturday final
plans were being laid for his trip to
Kiev the decision to go was taken on
Friday the arrangements had been
discussed over several months
the template was established last year
when the Secretary of State and the
defense secretary visited Ukraine
overnight train small Entourage blacked
out windows
the White House kept a tight lid on the
news even issuing Biden's schedule for
how you would spend Monday in Washington
even as he was traveling half a world
away the Americans stand with you and
the world stands with you
Keith has captured a part of my heart I
must say
It's Not Unusual for presidents to make
trips to conflict zones Barack Obama did
it in Afghanistan Donald Trump Iraq but
both times the U.S controlled the
airspace
that's what made Biden's trip more
dangerous and that's why the White House
told the Russians just hours before to
avoid any mishaps which could spark a
bigger problem on the ground the
security had to be unbelievable by the
Ukrainian side because the US doesn't
have a military presence in Ukraine and
so you've got air defense security to
worry about you've got these possible
elements on the ground uh and it
required the the shutting down
essentially of Kiev to traffic for a
couple of hours
when he traveled to Poland last year
President Biden was reportedly Keen to
cross the border but was overruled by
his secret service the people who
protect him this time with more notice
they could make it work Security will be
ramped up here when Joe Biden makes a
major address to Mark the first
anniversary of the Ukraine war but no
matter what he says what will be
remembered more than the speech is the
visit that came before it Alan Fisher Al
Jazeera Warsaw